luke weaver on the bound for the
diamondbacks back today from a right
shoulder stream in the american league
west there's a ground ball into the ship
and ahmet's got it and fires to first
for the out to take care of corona worth
for out number two now but shadow bats
with the bases empty
skied along the right field line for
pavon smith and foul ground
and he's got it good start for look
weaver diamondbacks coming up against
you darvish you darvish on the bond
today for the friars believe it or not
in search of his first win of the season
against these snakes
rips this one to first but it's picked
nicely by hosmer on the backhand and
he'll tag the bag one pitch one out
bring up cattell martay he has been a
padres killer
all kinds of room over there and martay
bunsen just passed the bag
acres of space for cattell
and there's a base hit that's a freebie
he's had thoughts about going two right
there if he burned it a little bit
harder down that third base line he
probably does end up at second base
on the ground right side and coming
profar will flip and out of the jam is
darvish drivers back to work second and
he gave up a couple of hits in the first
or two of our show from darvish swinging
a miss strike him out first of the day
for darvish one down in the second well
he just threw fastballs right by varsha
that time that's another fastball out
over the play but right by him
swinging to miss and he's able to strike
out ahmed elevated there with a fastball
at 94.
that's the second strike out of the
inning and of the outing for you darvish
swinging a miss and got him to chase
and after the slider he ends up striking
out the side scoreless through two
so weavers could try to go through the
first three innings here nine up nine
down one two pitch
right there called strike three first
strikeout for luke weaver back for the
first time in more than three months
he's set down eight straight well here's
marty who dumped a bunt down the third
base line his first time up
just chopping over there again
martay two for two for pavon smith who
pops up his first time
havens sends one to left center marty's
on the move that gets all the way to the
wall cattell will score it's an rbi
double for pavon smith and the
diamondbacks strike first so dimebags
have first and third and now van meter
at the plate
that kicks away here comes pavement and
it's two-nothing d-backs
[Applause]
van meter hits it deep to right field
that's gone
josh van meter that's his fifth make it
four nothing i believe that was supposed
to be a sinker he elevates it up out
over the plate van meter gets full
extension and barrels it to right field
two down in a run around first base four
runs in this inning the batter as we
mentioned will be nick ahmed that was
only a few weeks ago
ahmed with a base hit mccarthy coming
home with run number five five against
darvish in the third this is nick ahmed
gets a slider that stays in the strike
zone this time partly off with contact
with two outs in the inning and he'll
score easily back take a five-nothing
lead
machado at third long throw
and hoswick can't scoop and ahmed on the
move heading for third that is it for
you darvish he departs first and third
two men out and josh rojos will bat for
the second time this setting deja vu all
over again
and that one rolls into right field
ahmed is home at six nothing
diamondbacks diamondbacks doing all the
little things right today mandy machado
will get his shot at luke weaver here in
the fourth inning with nobody on and two
down
by the first baseman smith and quickly
into the right field corner over his
mccarthy to play it as machado's headed
for two and he'll slide in safely
two out double from manny machado
fernando tatis jr
lying down to left his first time up
strike three ring them up a strike out
of tatis to strand machado four
scoreless for luke weaver he leads it
six nothing david band cleanup today and
he's rewarded tory lavella with a couple
of hits
up the middle
out there to the first oh
safe there
he was like diving and tagging the bag
at the same time
and then threw from his backside to
first base we had to reach to get that
ball and then go back to tag two options
and now pro far the batter
pitcher spot behind profar tommy pham in
the on deck circle that backs up
pavement bearhead recovers and they get
the out
the juggling act by pavon smith they got
it done the glove the bare hand recovery
handing out it's six nothing
diamondbacks new pitcher for the padres
welcome back to nelson le miss
swing and a miss on a very high pitch i
was a high slider that time and ahmed
strikes out on it for the first out of
the fifth inning
by him at 97. still got the good gas two
down countdown full they could tell
martay
swing and a miss and lumet with his
third strike out of the inning
nice return for janelson lumet one down
here in the sixth inning here's trent
grisham
fly ball hit down the right field line
that ball is back and that ball is gone
into the bullpen home run for trent
grisham his 14th of the year gets the
padres on the board just above the knees
he went out and got it and just makes it
over into the pen
oh for two so far in the ball game flew
out in the second inning got caught
looking at strikes in the fourth
fly ball to deep right field back goes
mccarthy it's over his head and one hops
the wall
that's heading for second base standing
is fernando's got himself a lead off
double to begin the seventh inning one
down in the seventh inning that'll bring
up will myers
third with one away and myers drives one
to deep left field back goes peralta at
the wall
that's gone will myers with a two-run
home run and the padres cut the lead in
half his 16th home run of the year
two-run shot for san diego in the
seventh here come the padres the two
down now in a runner and scoring
position it'll be manny machado's
opportunity to get the padres on the
board for a third inning in a row one on
a machado and he hits it in the left
center field can man marty get over
there he does it hung up and he makes
the catch on the run to retirement shot
oh and then the ending back to back hit
batsman will load the bases for the
diamondbacks here in the bottom of the
eighth inning and all of a sudden austin
adams has a hole to dig out of
and he walked in a run he hit two
batters then walked the guy with the
bases full
and make it seven to three andre is down
to their final out it'll be in the
person of will myers
[Applause]
myers strikes out looking to end the
ball game ends a frustrating day for the
padres
as the diamondbacks grab the final game
of this series
padres win the series taking two out of
three but today it's the diamondbacks
they win it 8-3